foreign
Scott's in Allentown Pennsylvania hey
Scott what's up
how you doing sir better than we deserve
how can John and I help
uh calling about a uh a lovely mental
and heart tug of war on putting myself
and my wife on our future first to wipe
out my mistakes of debt versus helping
my parents who should be in near
retirement but have basically not set a
great example and they don't have to act
together at all
foreign
so it's been a struggle for me because I
my wife had no debt coming into our
marriage three years ago I do and it's
my responsibility listening to you to
get it all taken care of and then my my
dad's business failed and they didn't
ask for help but then I said hey let me
at least pay your rent this month while
you go find work you need to you know
people roof over your head dad because
that's what you taught me my whole life
and now I'm rolling into 2023. it's like
hey you know I I did a good thing I need
to go back to focusing on me happy wife
happy life
um
yeah so that's where I'm mentally and
emotionally at right now
are they still coming to you for money
or you still feel like you need to feed
them
no they didn't even want that they said
no we'll figure it out we don't want to
be a burden I'm like uh you already are
so
uh that was my choice volunteering and I
talked it over to my wife she said fine
if that's what you want to do for your
Christmas gift for uh yeah you know
because we're married she's like fine
you can give them a month's rent take
care of it I made them give me their
landlord so I paid them directly and
that was just me because I just I was
losing my mind and I just didn't want
them my parents on the street my younger
brother and I have agreed like well we
told them this over the past three years
that the business was going to fail and
they didn't listen so they put
themselves here so there's that tug of
war of like here's here's the deal Scott
there is no tug of war
the greatest gift you can give your
parents long term is for you to take
care of yourself now
okay and if you continue to fight your
wife and her if you've been how long
have you been married three years you
said
yeah totally Bloomer I'm not 45 so
that's all right that's right um I'm
just saying uh from a guy who's been
married two decades if that's what you
want to do
is
um spouse speak for stupid wow I
wouldn't do that
all right so if worse than that she said
oh we'll make that your Christmas gift
just uh just a highlight exactly I don't
agree with so you have played your I
wouldn't do that if I were you card
three years in congratulations you spent
it earlier than most of us do but you'd
have
the greatest gift you could give your
parents long term is is to be
financially stable on your own and
you're not you're probably even close
like I've been really I just I shut down
all podcasts the past three weeks and
just have been catching up as much as
possible because I used to listen to a
year or two ago and then I stopped and
now I'm like it literally flipped the
flipping switch in my brain and I told
my wife this I said I've not been a good
husband this I shouldn't even have debt
right now I was like I should have had
this paid off a year ago this is
ridiculous because she came from a
family with intelligence of money she
has no debt Hey Hey listen listen that's
in your past who cares you're here right
now what are you gonna do tomorrow
listening to a bunch of podcasts is a
waste of your time if you're not acting
and you listen to what your podcast and
got all fired up and then you sent your
Christmas money to your parents
yeah well also I also paid off a line of
credit last month and just paid off half
the credit card this month good I'm a
very successful salesperson good so get
after it yeah she sees the action get
after get after it get after it get
yourself out of debt get yourself an
emergency fund get yourself on the road
to Financial Freedom yourself and then
if your parents come to you and say hey
can you support us and you sit down with
your wife and y'all come up with
um here's what our boundaries are and
here's what we're able to do so that we
don't end up in the same situation
that's a whole that's that's a next year
year after that year after that
challenge right now right now you got to
get yourself stable
I love this now how do you get the wife
to my wife to because again she doesn't
have my mistakes so her point is well
and I guess hey we're in this together
like I'm not no joke she's got a good
amount of money and she's like well
like that was mine before the marriage
blah blah blah blah and I'm fine with
that no no no no no no then y'all don't
have a marriage you all have a Business
Partnership
that's what it feels like but I want to
I want to bring it up I'm like uh am I
being a jerk saying that like
I'm just trying to approach that in a
teamwork responsibility thing and I'm
like babe I was like if we just have
that one savings account my mistakes are
gone and then I can just pay you back
pay us back
that's no paying back so the old book of
common prayer said unto thee you know
for richer for poor and sickness and
health unto thee all my worldly Goods I
pledge that was the old marriage vows we
quit doing those type of things a
generation or so ago or two generations
ago and that was a mistake because the
proper way to have a high quality
marriage
is to share your entire life
right there's no hold back
and so you're not going to sort of help
her if she gets cancer
right you're not you know and well you
used to smoke so you're just gonna have
to deal with that cancer thing on your
own
and you're not going to do that you're
going to go well I mean a lady I married
used to smoke and now she's got cancer
and I'm going to take care of her richer
for poorer and sickness and health unto
thee all my worldly Goods I pledge and
so it's not the money
and it's not paying Penance for the past
it's an indication of where the future
is going that we're combining our
incomes or combining our assets and
we're going to make decisions together
from this point forward
and we're going to take into
consideration that she was has a natural
skill or a family skill on money that's
above yours and you've got some catching
up to do on that skill
but you need to be sitting down doing
that if you can't do that you guys need
to sit down with a good marriage
counselor because you currently are
operating like roommates relationally I
want to revisit the last call uh because
it is a common
thing out there for second marriages and
late marriages
have more trouble combining their
finances than two 22 year olds that get
married because number one two 20 year
olds get married usually don't have
anything to combine but uh but the other
thing is they're just not there there's
no old dog trying to teach New Tricks
here if you were burned in a marriage
before it makes it hard to trust again
and
um and if you um
you know if you've lived independent and
been responsible and saved up some money
and then you marry someone who has not
been independent and has not been
responsible and has not saved up any
money in his debt
I can see how you would resent that idea
but the thing I don't get I can't get my
head around is how that doesn't go with
the marriage package like you didn't
know you were signing up for this it's
all you see it in late later marriages
it's a
it's almost a a compromise like I I just
want to spend time with you I like you
you're hilarious you bring joy to my
life I want to spend time with you I'm
not gonna do business with you right and
I've got friends like some of my closest
friends in the world I love them I'd go
to war with them I ain't hiring them
right it's it's kind of like that
when he talked the whole time I kept
thinking oh she doesn't trust you
and whether she might love you she but
she does not trust how you do business
or handle money not not in a in an
Integrity Way but she doesn't trust his
um Financial emotional maturity that's
right and giving money to the parents
who are also irresponsible correct
um
added to her suspicions out of guilt and
all that well I mean she's like this
guy's not trustworthy he's he does
stupid butt stuff
you know and that's what's running
through her head but there there's a
thing here that has to happen
um
uh in order to have the highest
probability of becoming very wealthy
you've got to work together and combine
right all the data tells us that in
order to have a high quality marriage
you cannot operate two separate balance
sheets it just does not lend us where
your treasure is your heart is also and
when you combine your finances you're
essentially combining your life you're
combining your future you're combining
your dreams you're combining your fears
and not doing that is sort of like uh
you know I'm gonna just walk around an
ankle deep in the pool of marriage I'm
not going to get in the deep water it's
just like going up to bat and you're
only putting one hand on the baseball
bat when you try to swing it well it's
just not it's not going to be a fact
that's a good one right it's not gonna
be effective
um and I think in this kind of in this
situation it's a both end
he needs to admit yes the way I've done
it isn't work
so we're going to follow a unified plan
and I will commit to it he said I'm a
great salesman he's one of those he
shows himself a great salesman I'm a
great salesman and one of the things I
suffered with most of us that are great
salesmen suffer with this we think we
cannot earn our stupidity uh
and we'll just go make some more money
because making money is easy yeah all
right but but it's another scheme
another idea you know it's it's the way
to fix this is I'll just make more money
and it's and because I can always go do
that and um you know I still have to
watch myself on that after even teaching
this for 30 years yeah I said I can just
fix this I'll just go make some more
money because I've always been able to
make money but you know and so up until
I was 28 years old I couldn't keep it at
all and I can get it it's like uh you
had a hole in your live well man you
could catch a lot of fish they just they
just went right out the back of the boat
yeah and we're shocked that when we open
the thing up there's nothing in there we
caught a bunch of fish where did they go
they go yeah it's like the whole thing's
just emptying out so yeah I think uh but
it's the the note is to those of you
that have married late especially or
second marriages especially or are
considering that you need to make this
part of the deal
not because Ramsey said so but because
it's best for your relationship and it
increases your probability of wealth
building you're going to have a higher
quality situation all the way around
when the dude in this case becomes
trustworthy worthy of trust because his
actions are honorable and responsible
and mature and she quits treating him
like a pendulum little kid who is messed
up and I'm going to withhold
uh
my checkbook right from this marriage
right and that's going to require both
people usually to learn a new skill
which is how to have a hard conversation
yeah how to tell each other I don't know
how to do this I'm not comfortable with
you taking care of the money like
instead of going if that's what you want
to do and that's your Christmas present
yeah that was very motherly yeah not
very well very like Aunt susaney yeah
right that was not wifey that was
motherly yeah that was like you're an
idiot little boy just go ahead you're
gonna make a mess spend all your mowing
money on Mountain dude yeah that's right
if you want to do it yeah that's that's
what that was I've heard that tone a
time or two myself so I literally hear
that on a weekly basis
but
it's